a very good evening folks uh this is
your host Russia uh today we have Dr
purushottam with us uh who will be
taking us through uh the program preview
for plant picks pgp program in cloud
computing
I can see a lot of folks are joining in
would love to know where you post our
family uh let me just uh introduce
myself on the chat here you can type in
your chat so I'm I'm Russia and I am
from Bangalore India
you can just introduce yourselves on
Saturday while people are joining in and
we'll be starting in few minutes
and uh good luck to know like uh where
are you from
yeah yes hi Russia thanks for the
opportunity so um my name is
from nagpur uh India
and uh yeah thank you yes
some
working as a cloud architect
yeah and assistant professor in Sri
ramdeva College of engineering and
management nagpur
and I'm a Microsoft certified trainer aw
certified trainer as well yeah
awesome that's great
um happy to have you here
I can see a lot of folks are joining in
uh would love to know where are you
folks from uh so you can type on chat
here I'll just type again like where I'm
from I'm from Bangalore India and as Dr
purushottam said he's from nagpur India
so where are you from uh you can type on
chat here okay I can see if your
response is coming in already uh they
just saw is from Dubai UA hi Tejas happy
to have you here uh all other folks who
are joining in let's wait for a few
minutes to start so we will be uh taking
you through the program preview for
caltex pgp and cloud computing and Dr
purushottam uh is here with us who
actually will be helping you uh in uh
taking you through the program review I
can see folks are already responding on
chat I can see Vishnu is from Bangalore
hey Vishnu hi Praveen from Chennai uh I
can see uh labia from mizoram India hey
labia hi uh I can see later on from this
Ethiopia oh interesting I can see India
we have actually gotten a lot of folks
from different different parts of India
and even outside of India welcome
everyone folks who are just joining now
uh just to let you know that we will be
starting the session in few minutes
Meanwhile we're just settling in and you
can just tell us where are you from uh
so I am from Bangalore India we can just
type in on chart here uh I'll just type
in here I can see pratiksha is
good my hometown
happy to see you
awesome uh so folks who are just joining
now just to let you know that we're
starting in few minutes and meanwhile
what you can do is you can just
introduce yourself on chat here you can
tell us where you're from I can see
zeeshan is from I can see nigashi is
from Tamil Nadu okay hi hi pratiksha
okay uh I think uh
we can wait for few more minutes and
then we can start meanwhile uh we will
take you through the Q a uh part as well
and basically how what are the ground
rules of this session
before we go there let's talk about the
agenda of today's session uh so
obviously uh we'll be exploring more
about you basically what are you looking
for in your career and uh also we'll be
talking about cloud computing careers
and how Caltech CDMA uh helps you in in
getting your career hired and also
you'll be sharing learner outcomes and
uh in the enrollment steps and also
we'll be taking q a uh from the Q a
section so in case you have any queries
what you can do is you will see a q a
pop-up on your laptop if you join from
your laptop if you join from your mobile
you can see a query section where you
can go and ask your questions so feel
free to go and ask the questions there
in case you're putting your questions on
a chat I'm so sorry uh we usually get a
lot of messages on chat here so I might
miss out on that and I would I wouldn't
want to do that so I would want all of
your questions to be answered by Dr
purushottam uh about the cloud computing
career and the program by Caltech as
well so I would love to know your
questions will be taking questions uh in
between and all towards the end so uh
stay tuned uh we'll be talking more
about that I can see a lot of
introductions coming on the chat here so
hello everyone
and uh folks who just joined now just to
let you know that we are starting the
session we're just talking about the
agenda here so uh I can see folks are
introducing themselves where they're
from good to see so many folks from
different different parts of India and
even outside of India welcome everyone
uh yeah yeah awesome so uh folks who
have to join now you can put down your
questions in the Q a section uh of uh
join free mobile or laptop uh if you put
that on the chart here I might miss out
on that and I wouldn't want that uh I
would love for your questions to be
answered uh from Andhra Pradesh hey hi
awesome so uh I think let's move on to
the next
so uh before we start uh I would
actually love to know more about you uh
so uh
so I would love to know like how much
experience do you have uh like are you
currently studying uh are you like a
fresher you just have three to three
years of experience are you a mid
professional you have three to five
years of experience or do you have more
than five years of experience you're
quite experienced uh so you can just
choose their options on the screen and
if you've joined from your laptop or
mobile and just submit the code so I can
get to know you better so I can see uh
the responses coming in a lot of you
folks have already submitted your
answers that's pretty great good to see
uh a responsive audience here uh and I
can see half of the audience has
responded they're currently studying
that's great and uh more than more than
one third of the audience is saying they
are more than uh you know four or five
years of experience and we have gotten
few freshers here as well so I will be
closing the poll in 10 seconds so uh
folks who have joined you will be seeing
a question on your screen uh uh
basically you can just go and select the
option which actually suits you best in
terms of experience you have so if
you're currently studying in choose that
if you have zero to three years of
experience if you have three to five
years of experience or if you have more
than five years of experience so I would
love to see would love to see uh what
folks are voting and uh I'll be closing
the poll in five seconds so five four
three two one uh let me end the poll
thank you so much for voting guys
okay let me share the results
okay uh as we can see that uh half of
the folks are currently studying and uh
we can see that one third of the forks
are freshers and one other ones are of
the fourth uh folks are having more than
five years of experience and we have
gotten some uh you know mid
professionals as well
good to have you here
okay
and before starting session let me tell
you a little bit about simply learn so
simply learn uh is the world's number
one boot camp and uh we have more than
13 years of digital skills training
experience uh and uh we have trained uh
5 million plus users uh students who are
from over 150 plus countries and uh we
are very proud of that uh we are proud
that we are transforming lives by and
traveling people we are Disney skills so
uh welcome to the session folks who have
just joined
and uh
so uh who will be taking us through the
pgp program in uh cloud computing uh by
Caltech uh so just want to welcome Dr
purushottam here with us uh doctor uh
would you like to tell us a little bit
about yourself and your experience yeah
sure so thank you for uh giving me the
opportunity to be here so hello everyone
um my name is uh has already stated
purushottam and I'm assistant professor
in uh SRI ramdeva College of engineering
and management nagpur India and I
specialize in cloud computing
um in Microsoft Azure awsn operating
systems my Google Scholar corporate
trainer Microsoft certified trainer AWS
certified trainer three times certified
on AWS having the top level
certification in the architect tier of
AWS that is architect professional
Microsoft Azure certified architect and
administrator as well and I've been
associated with Caltech University
um which is rated as I think the second
topmost University in the world uh for
delivering their postgraduate program in
cloud computing through simply learn and
I'm also associated with many other
consultancies and have delivered
multiple corporate trainings on cloud
platforms for multiple multinational
companies like every Africa Vodafone UK
TCS
most response are in declined etc for
AWS Solutions architect and as Azure
architect level trainings as well right
so I'm happy to be here and would uh be
uh Keen to go in and uh tell you more on
to the
um learning experience that you people
can have if you join this program thank
you
uh great thank you so much
I would love to know like how did you
get uh to this point in your career
Journey can you tell us more about that
yeah sure so basically see
um
I was interested in in in uh I mean I've
been a computer science guy from the
start and then when Cloud came into
picture I was basically interested in
doing it so I started my research
actually I've done my PhD also in cloud
computing and Source scheduling in cloud
from vit velor so um I was uh somewhat
interested because see everything
nowadays is moving towards cloud like uh
whatever you have it in the on-premisis
you have it in the cloud uh Let It Be
Your servers let it be a storage
database is everything so the point is
um when everything is in cloud and
um probably it said that by 2025 almost
90 of the companies will move towards
cloud and right now also many of the
companies are in cloud and it's not just
the it that is in Cloud but almost every
business is moving towards Cloud because
they want to have that infrastructure
hosted by the cloud provider so that
they can concentrate on their Core
Business okay
um so the point is that the interest
from the cloud came in uh right from uh
let's say 2015 and
then I've been in in this background and
the more I get into it uh the more I uh
interest I uh developed into it and uh
regarding the training business so
anyways I'm very passionate about
teaching and training so I'm into it and
really enjoying it yeah
awesome great thank you so much for a
great introduction
thank you uh so uh I think we'll be
starting with about careers in cloud
computing
uh so uh Dr purushottam when you see
cloud is the backbone of the digital
economy uh how we have gotten to this
point can you tell us more about this
yeah correct so it's the backbone of the
digital economy I mean see
um I mean uh nowadays see what happens
I'll give you an example let's say uh if
there is an organization uh let's say
Netflix for example uh which is hosted
on AWS correct so Netflix is managing
its complete services on AWS so now what
Netflix has done is
um and Netflix has given its
infrastructure for hosting it on the
cloud provider that is AWS so what AWS
is doing is AWS is managing the
infrastructure of Netflix and saying
Netflix that hey Netflix uh you can do
your core job of uh your core business
that is the entertainment business so
now Netflix they can purely concentrate
on their core job of entertainment uh
business and let their infrastructure be
managed by the cloud provider that is
AWS in this case
um otherwise what would have happened is
if they would have managed their servers
in their on-premises environment then
they would have had to uh put their
efforts on two things that is one is
managing their Core Business of Intel
entertainment and also managing the
infrastructure that is required for
running their Core Business correct so
now their focus is just on their Core
Business of entertainment and their
infrastructure that is required for
running their business is being managed
by the cloud provider so that is how you
can see it is actually
um
what you say is it is the backbone of
digital economy because now uh all of
the infrastructure of this Netflix is be
managed by the cloud provider and then
Netflix can concentrate on their Core
Business and do a lot of good things in
their Core Business can think of uh
improving or can think of uh being the
market leader in their core business
rather than managing their
infrastructure okay so not just Netflix
this is just an example but for every
other business case it's um like they
can just concentrate on their Core
Business and let the infrastructure be
managed by the cloud provider and there
is another advantage to that also like
they don't have to manage those physical
servers so so capital expenditure that
is capex is almost zero uh when you
adopt to Cloud when the companies move
towards Cloud so it's all about
operational expenditure that is required
for managing and maintaining the virtual
servers
um and and they don't have to buy the
physical server so so the capital
expenditure is almost zero okay so now
so the profits have increased and the
businesses are able to concentrate on
their core business so um that has
become the buzzword and uh to to to put
put above that
um it's not about uh just the
established companies but even the
startups
um let's say if I have to uh like have
have my own startup and I don't want to
put uh the money in the capital
expenditure so I can just go to Cloud I
can set up my complete company in the
cloud and in a virtual Manner and save
on the capital expenditure so even if I
don't have that uh capitals uh Capital
um uh income to to actually start up my
company then also I can start my
business start my company in cloud and I
can really do good in that isn't it so
um that's how it is called as the
backbone of digital economies
um oh that's pretty interesting
go to the next one uh what are the
career paths people can follow in cloud
computing okay yeah so now when you when
you move towards Cloud so as I said that
um almost everything that you have it in
on-premises you have it in the cloud so
now when you have everything that you
have in on-premises you have it in the
cloud so when you get into Cloud so
which role you can opt for so guys you
have a lot of roles like being in Cloud
you can be a cloud engineer you can be a
cloud developer you can be a cloud
architect you can become a cloud
database administrator you can become a
cloud security engineer Cloud devops
engineer plus many more now
I'll tell you uh if you start in cloud
and if you have a good good exposure on
cloud if you learn cloud and let's say
um if you are not having a very good
experience but then you have good
knowledge in Cloud then you can become a
cloud engineer then if you are on the
development side okay then uh you can
become a cloud developer
sorry yeah so you can even become a
cloud developer if you are from the
development end in fact there are good
good certifications available in the
public Cloud platforms like AWS
um having AWS developer associate then
you have Microsoft Azure developer that
is az204
so if you are from the development
background if you have some good
knowledge of the programming languages
then you can become a cloud developer by
going in with any of the certifications
like AWS Cloud developer or Microsoft
Azure developer associate is it 204 okay
so that is there then Cloud architect so
you can become a cloud architect if if
you are from the architect end in your
on-premises or otherwise also you can
become a cloud Architect by by going in
through the courses on cloud architect
like you have is at 305 that is
Microsoft Azure architect okay then uh
you have uh AWS certified Solutions
architect associate AWS certified
Solutions architect professional which I
have done okay to become a cloud
architect okay and but if you want to be
a cloud architect in any organization in
an Enterprise case you need to have some
good years of experience as well to
promote or to get into the cloud
architect role but that doesn't mean
that you cannot do the certification on
cloud architect if you do if you if you
gain a certification on cloud architect
probably initially you can become a
cloud in you can start as a cloud
engineer and then later when you gain
some good experience you can be promoted
to the role of cloud architect Okay then
if you are from the database and guys if
you are a database guy okay so
um you can do the cloud database
administrator uh you can become a cloud
database administrator by doing uh the
either Cloud architect certification
there also you are taught about the
databases even in the admins but if you
want to get into the deep dive into
databases then you can go for AWS
database specialty or in Azure also you
can go with database specialty
certifications okay
then of course when you talk about cloud
guys so security is of time concern and
let me tell you all these Cloud
providers especially the market leaders
like AWS assure they have got a lot of
security mechanisms to keep your data
really really secured okay so uh what
are those mechanisms how to use those
mechanisms how to make your data very
secured in the cloud because guys it's
it's your responsibility also to make
the data secured like AWS Azure will
give you the security mechanisms but
then to apply those in the right manner
is something that you will have to do it
so a cloud security engineer can really
um get you uh done that okay so you can
become a cloud security engineer and you
can make sure that all the clients data
the company's data is very secured in
the cloud okay plus a cloud architect
you can also make design decisions like
if if a particular uh objective can be
accomplished by using n number of
services so which service should be used
which would which which would be good as
far as the company budgets are concerned
and as far as the other requirements of
the projects are concerned okay so that
can be there and then of course uh
devops engineer so now on to this Cloud
devops engineer Russia if you have some
time elaborate a bit on this
uh yes sir please go ahead yeah yeah
yeah sure so uh in Cloud devops engineer
see I'll give you an example
um let's say guys um
uh you must have heard about waterfall
model in the software engineering okay
uh wonderful model in the agile model of
develop deployment or development so
what happens in waterfall model is that
was used in the organizations in the
previous days normally that is not quite
used right now so what used to happen in
waterfall model is let's say uh if the
client had a requirement okay uh he
wanted some project some software to be
built from you so he would come to you
he would give this requirement to you
your your business head then it would be
passed to the manager and then manager
would give it to the team lead and then
we it is given to the developers and the
developers would create that would code
and create that software guys and then
we'll uh test it deploy it and then it
would be shown to the client okay in one
go it is like and if that software had n
number of modules five modules let's say
all of them were created at once and
were shown uh to the client uh as an end
product okay now now if what client had
asked and what you have built if there
is a huge gap in that or if it is
totally different then client would say
hey man I didn't ask for this one I mean
what you have developed is totally a
different thing than what I had expected
or I had uh asked for I had given my
requirement off so he would be like I'm
not done with this so you'll have to
rework and uh you will have to create it
again okay so then it is a complete
rework guys it's a complete rework so
then you would go and then you would do
that stuff again and then again if it is
not as per clients requirement then
again it is the it is a sheer wastage of
time and resources and money so
um this is not good actually so then we
came into the agile model of deployment
and now in agile model of deployment
what used to what used to happen is uh
that if a if a software is to be built
in five modules so let's not create or
let's not build all those five modules
in one go but do it one by one so there
would create one module
and then it would show it would be shown
to the client and the client's input
would be taken that if it is as per the
client's requirement and if client says
yes it is as per my requirement then the
developer would go and create another
module if the client says no Then he
would rework on the first module and
then uh show it again to the client so
here guys the point is that if he has to
rework he has to work on rework on one
module at a time not on the entire
project not on the entire software okay
so uh here the task of the developer and
the team is reduced the reworking task
okay and but at the same time what if
they are developing the project and
modules the software and modules so they
would test the model when they build one
module they'll test it they'll deploy it
and show it to the client then again
they'll they'll create another module
develop it test it deploy it and show it
to the client so this is what they used
to do okay so here the testing
deployment is happening again and again
again and again okay so now the point is
that if you have manual testers to take
care of testing so then their job would
be increased okay and then it can be
texting to do this job again and again
manually so then came in the devops
tools then came and was the devops tools
so these devops tools have the
capability to automate this deployment
to automate this deployment means what
the testing deployment will happen in an
automated fashion okay
so the client will create uh sorry the
the developer would create a module and
then he'll test it deploy it and show it
to the client so this will happen in an
automated fashion then if he would make
any change to that module or will create
another modules then again the testing
deployment of that module will happen in
an automated fashion guys so that is
possible with the devops tools okay so
there are multiple tools like uh you
have Jenkins terraform GitHub
um so so all these tools are used as
devops tools and they help in automation
process and these are the open source
tools so likewise there
um similar to these Jenkins terraform
ansible these devops tools that are
there in the on-premises similar to them
you have Cloud proprietary Tools in AWS
Azure like in AWS you have code commit
code pipeline code deploy okay so all
these devops tools can be used to
automate this deployment whenever client
will create a module that would be
automatically compiled that is built
tested deployed Okay then if he makes
any change to the code then again that
complete compilation testing deployment
will happen in an automated fashion so
no human inter interference or no
interaction is required this will this
will be tested deployed automatically
okay again and again so this is possible
with these devops tools and of course if
you become a devops engineer you will of
course be learning how you can create
these devops tools how you can create
the complete uh integration complete
deployment pipeline that is CI CD
pipeline plus more into the devops tools
and you can do these develop deployments
in an automated fashion yeah so of
course you can get into that role as
well yeah there is a good certification
in AWS called as is at 400 they work for
devops professional in fact in AWS also
you have Cloud devops engineer
certification yeah
thank you wow that's a lot of career
paths in just one category of cloud
computing skills uh but there's always a
dilemma right like where do you get
started like there are so many career
paths right there there are so many
scares to uh be updated so where how do
you get started where do you get started
like you're always stuck there what
would you suggest for folks who want to
get started but are stuck in what career
path to choose see if you are stuck up
now I would suggest you start with the
uh like the uh uh basic course in cloud
computing uh let's say in public cloud
like in AWS you can start with AWS
certified Cloud practitioner on in
ensure with Azure fundamentals and
um then you can progress further and
then once like let's say if I say AWS
Cloud practitioner so this course will
give you the know-how about the cloud
that means all the different Services uh
many of them you will come to know in
AWS In This Cloud practitioner course
but then you will be jack off those
services not the master of anyone okay
but then you will come to know that okay
what which service is doing and um you
can get a familiarity and then you can
decide based on your interest at okay I
am an admin guy so I should go with
admin certification if I am a developer
so I should go with developer
certification if I am an architect so I
should go with that kind of a
certification so that will help you and
and these certifications and these
courses like the uh basic practitioner
level courses helps you to get into the
insights of what is there in different
services in Cloud platform and then you
can decide and of course with any
certification that you do you can become
a cloud engineer initially if you don't
have the experience also yeah well that
makes sense uh while you were speaking
we are getting a lot of questions maybe
let's take like few questions uh for now
uh so I can see uh that as sales
professional what all paths are
available in this role
uh what all parts so anyways the parts
are stated here like you can become a
cloud engineer Cloud developer right so
these are the different parts different
roles uh that you can be into if you
become or if you get yourself uh trained
into Cloud platforms yeah
uh and what are the certifications or
requirements for cloud security engineer
is security Security Plus a good
certification for this job a
continuation of the previous question
okay so uh the sorry uh the different
um what are the certification or
requirements of cloud security engineer
okay so um
the certifications as I said uh you can
uh there is a certification in AWS
called as AWS certified security
specialty okay
um plus you have uh in Easy 400 the
security certification so in in Azure so
uh you can get into those certifications
uh okay if you want to be a security
engineer plus apart from that if you go
with admin or architect level
certifications in in the public Cloud
platforms there also you will learn
about the security aspects okay but if
you want to get into the details of it
maybe more into it so then you can go
with the security specialty
certifications like AWS certified
security specialty engineer and so on
right um and then a Security Plus a good
certification for this job uh so see of
course if you if you um if you are a
security guy if you get interest into it
and then if you go for such
certifications then you you stand a
bright chances of uh getting a job or
getting your role into a into a security
engineer and of course if you are no
ways into the cloud so again as I said
um what is the good starting point is
you can directly start with security
engineer or first get the basics of
cloud platform let's say in AWS you can
get with AWS practitioner uh
certification or you know sure ez900
that is a sure fundamentals and then you
can get into or that you can switch to
security certification as well but plus
as I said if you be a architect or or an
admin
um you get uh good insights into the
security services as well
uh I hope that answers your question uh
so we have few more questions we will
take it in some time uh let's move on to
the next part uh so uh what how do
people move across a different role and
get the salary hike they have been
looking for in cloud computing
yeah so uh get the salary hike okay so
see as I told you if you don't have the
experience
um and you have good knowledge on cloud
platform but you don't have the good
experience then you can start with the
cloud engineer and this uh What uh the
the salaries are shown here are uh like
uh they they depend on
um companies to companies okay
organizations to organizations so um
annual salaries for cloud developers in
India uh you can see it starts with five
lakhs per annum and then you can get
into up to 22 lakhs per annum and uh
then for cloud Architects it starts with
10 lakhs and then you can reach up to 33
lakhs per annum but guys I have my like
I have a few examples also like one of
my friend he's a cloud architect of
course he's at a senior level into
Amazon and um he's earning more than 50
lakhs also so this 33 legs is not the um
it's mentioned as it's as the top Mark
but it is not actually the only talk Top
Mark is there are salaries more than
this also in the cloud architect domain
that you'll see
uh definitely your friend is breaking
salary barriers which has set in the
standards that's good to know that's
motivating for folks you know I must say
uh I think we have gotten one question
like by Praveen uh having a knowledge of
cloud is okay or certification is
mandatory
uh now this is something see uh I would
say
knowledge is very important okay if you
have a certification or if you don't
have a certification Cloud knowledge is
very important if you want to be in a
cloud role okay but then now the point
comes in that if you have a knowledge
but you don't have the certification so
you cannot actually showcase it in your
resume correct so the point is to
um to get into an interview you would
need that certification but to clear
that interview you'll need the knowledge
okay so uh probably when you apply for
the good mncs okay and you apply for
cloud role so uh these are hot cakes
like uh the AWS and Azure certification
so if you have them in your profile well
companies will prefer you I'll I'll tell
you uh companies are spending a lot of
money for getting their employees
trained by people like us okay and when
they are uh spending a lot of money for
getting their employees trained by us so
if they get some employee get some
person who is already trained into those
Cloud platform into those roles they'll
always prefer them to have it okay but
then how you can showcase that if you
are good in that okay so with your
certifications you are being stamped by
Microsoft uh or AWS that okay you have
cleared that means really you are good
into it so and you can show it in your
profile and uh that would impress the
organization and that would be an
impressive point in your interviews also
and then to crack an interview of course
the knowledge would be required
so I would say both
uh thank you so much um Praveen I hope
that answers your question uh and uh
just curious I'm just curious to know
like about your friend who actually
broke that salary barrier right uh what
does it take to reach there what does it
take to be reached there you know like
breaking the salary barely actually
getting those 50 lakh uh salary bracket
like what do you what do you suggest for
folks you know who are working hard uh
you know like yeah basically what do you
suggest for twice why are you working
I'll tell you uh the trend of mine is a
very good friend of mine and he is
basically uh like uh he has done his
engineering in Mechanicals okay he is a
b mechanical okay it's not done it in
computer science and then uh probably uh
he started as a mechanical engineer and
then he shifted into it but then when he
shifted into it he was very interested
and very passionate to learn more and
more he's he he is like of a colic
person and he is like always updating
himself learning new things
um so uh that's being uh his story and
that's I think is the mantra for his
success whatever he has achieved till
date because
um it's all about uh because it's all
about see the hard work and he's very
passionate he enjoys that so uh that's
how I think uh he has been able uh to
get into
um that kind of a role what he's into
today
um so even see I would I would not judge
his uh knowledge or his expertise by his
salary also because the knowledge and
expertise that he has got is way above
than his salary okay so it's all about
like it's not always about the salary
what you get but then
um being passionate or being always
learning actually
um
tell people how knowledgeable you are
because that comes in when you interact
with others correct so uh yeah that is
there uh so basically like being excited
to learn new skills and uh lifelong
learning
correct and of course you need to enjoy
while learning and and of course
concentrate on the process so results
may be less than 50 more than 50 can
always be there but then
um it's the process we have to
concentrate on definitely yeah
uh so uh for becoming a cloud
practitioner uh we required a lot of
up-to-date skills uh do people really
meet all of these skills to become
proficient proficient in cloud computing
no uh so see um you need to up to you
need up-to-date skills to be a cloud
practitioner so see as I told you when
you become a cloud practitioner you get
the uh What uh the the know-how about
different services in Cloud you become a
jackass many services but they're not
the master of them uh so it's like uh
you'll become the Jack of all these
services but then you don't have to be a
master of all these services to do good
in Cloud okay but then whatever the
services that are mentioned here if you
if you if you do Cloud architect Cloud
admin certifications you'll get a good
knowledge on these Services okay
um yeah
so that's it uh let me just give you a
bit uh into it so uh let's say if you if
you if in application migration you can
make migrate your workloads your
on-premises application into Cloud uh
which you also study in in the architect
certification in in Azure in AWS okay
um Plus in identity and access
management so this is really good for an
admin guy uh you can
um actually uh like you can create your
users in in in in cloud in AWS and Azure
and then you can manage their excesses
like uh with Services they should have
an access on which service they should
not have the access on so basically with
the help of role-based Access Control
with the help of policies you can manage
that and uh you should follow the
principle of least privilege as an
administrator that is let's say if a
person joins in as a database admin in
your organization so just give him
access to database resources not maybe
to other resources uh which are not
required by a database person okay and
if person joins us as a network
administrator so give him the access to
networking resources maybe not to the
database resources so you should manage
the excess in a manner so you should
follow the principle of least privilege
give him the access whatever is required
not more than that and of course not
less than that then of course Auto
scaling is also a pretty interesting
part like you do it uh if you become a
cloud admin or or maybe an architect you
have good services like you have AWS
Auto scaling and I'm sure you have a
short skill sets that can be used for
auto scaling so basically in Auto
scaling um what you do is you do the
scaling of servers like when the load is
uh High uh let's say take the example of
um the uh the the shopping websites
let's say Flipkart Amazon so during
their sale days uh the the the the
traffic on their website is not the same
so let's say um during Amazon's great
Indian sale the traffic on the their
website is not the same so
hypothetically let's say this their
website is running on 100 servers so
during sale days uh let's say if all
those hundred servers are more than 80
utilized so what should happen is more
number of servers should be created in
an automated fashion to handle that
additional load otherwise their website
May malfunction or may not perform to
the expectations or the website can
crash also so with auto scaling feature
more number of VMS would be created in
an automated manner during sale days to
cater to that additional load okay
um and then when the sale days are over
those new VMS can be automatically
terminated as well let's say if all the
VMS are less than 20 utilized uh CPU
utilize so those additional VMS can be
terminated as well so that you don't
have to pay for them so that Amazon
doesn't have to pay for them when uh the
additional servers are not required
right so that you come to know in that
tenant disaster recovery
you you get to know like
um how you can replicate your data your
servers across the regions so guys God
forbid if there is a natural Calamity in
one of the region and if the entire
region goes down so what what happens to
the data and the servers in that region
uh so if they are in stored in Cloud
also if the entire region goes down so
what will happen to the data and servers
in that region in Cloud so that will
also go down isn't it so then how you
can recover that so With Disaster
Recovery with Recovery Service Vault
service in Azure and with let's say
cross Regional application in AWS a
service what you can do is you can
actually replicate your data in another
region so that when this primary region
will go down you can still have access
to your data from the secondary region
from another region right guys and
that's why they say that people may die
but the data won't die okay so that's uh
the beauty in Cloud then web services
and API you come to know like um how you
can deploy your web services
websites in Cloud on the servers with
application programming interface you
can use it then of course in Cloud
migration in deployment how you can
migrate your workloads into Cloud okay
um from your on-premise is how you can
migrate your servers into Cloud your
databases your your applications and you
can deploy it in cloud and you have a
service like you have Azure migrate uh
which can be used for database migration
server Migration app migration from your
on-premise environment or any
third-party Cloud into Azure okay then
database management so
you can how you can manage your data
into the cloud so guys uh you have a lot
of services for managing the data in the
cloud databases so database related
Services you have a lot like uh you have
you have a solution for relational data
uh like you have RDS service in AWS
MySQL service in Azure that is for
relational data okay uh and guys gone
are the days when uh when it used to be
only relational data when one size used
to fit all okay now you have different
different kinds of data you don't just
have relational data you have not nosql
data also so how would you handle nosql
data like spreadsheet data Excel data so
you have uh these services for that also
like you have Cosmos DB in Azure you
have dynamodb in AWS that are the
solutions for nosql data plus uh you
have graph data like uh Facebook you are
using correct so you see this now like
if you are a friend to somebody and that
is friend to someone else so you get a
suggestion that that okay you are friend
to X person and that X person is friend
to a y person so do you want to make
friends with why person okay so uh those
kind of graph kind of relations uh can
be handled with graph databases guys you
have graph Data Solutions in uh in Cloud
also like you have AWS Neptune service
in AWS to take care of that okay so uh
probably for all different types of data
you have the services Plus Storage
services so whether you have any kind of
data like you have object data Block
Base data
images audios videos your hard disk your
shared data so you have the solution for
that like for object-based data images
audios videos you have S3 service in AWS
simply so simple storage service you
have blog blobs in Azure then flop block
related data like
um that can be used for virtual hard
disk uh okay so
uh where you can store operating system
files okay software files so for that
you have EBS storage elastic block
storage and AWS service then you have
file uh sorry
um which uh that is uh
in Azure you have a page blob in a short
to take care of that plus if you have
shared storage like uh this storage is
to be used by multiple VMS multiple
virtual machines at the same time okay
like for Hadoop Hadoop distributed file
systems so you have Azure file shares
for that in AWS you have EFS storage
elastic file storage so guys the point
is you have a solution for all different
types of storage Services as well right
so
um yeah that's there
a big thank you so much uh for uh for
amazing uh exclamation uh I can see uh
like a lot of questions coming on the Q
a section uh let me just read out loud
one uh question uh by parul Sir I have a
certificate a basic knowledge experience
in uh with AWS Cloud platform I know to
create an instance a market for storage
and to manage workload uh so which
category for cloud worker I will
classify myself uh whether Cloud
engineer a cloud admin or others
ah see uh
one second I know uh okay so you you
don't become a cloud uh admin uh with
this just this thing so and and to
become a cloud engineer you should uh
learn more into it right so
um you can get into the category of
cloud engineer right now but yes you
will have to learn more into it also and
if you want to become a cloud admin
again you'll have to uh get into the
knowledge of more services like IAM and
and and and stuff that you can easily
get it from uh if you if you study a
cloud admin or a cloud architect role
right
um thank you so much uh I hope that
answers your question uh I can see while
while you were speaking I also was
getting the question in my head and I
can see one question in the Q a section
as well uh what is the best place to
start in cloud computing with zero
experience you can you can start with a
cloud practitioner role and don't stop
there don't stop there uh go with either
Cloud admin or Cloud developer after
that if you are a development guy if you
are good in coding then go with Cloud
developer otherwise go with Cloud admin
which you don't need much of coding um I
think hardly any and then after you
become an administrator uh of course you
can get a good job and then you can
decide to get into the architect role
also even after becoming developer you
can you can you can get into the
architect role as well uh by going with
that certification so Cloud practitioner
but don't stop it practitioner because
practitioner enough may not yield you a
good job so after practitioner go with
either admin role admin certification or
the developer certification based on
your interest if you are good in coding
who and you are interested in developer
then go with that otherwise if you are
uh not then you can go with the admin
role as well if you are a systems guy
maybe
I hope that answers your question uh so
uh we'll be taking more q a questions uh
towards the end of the session uh so uh
I just had a question for you folks
uh we have talked about the job rules we
have talked about the salaries we have
talked about what skills do you need in
to get into cloud computing uh I know
you all are here because you are
interested in cloud computing so what's
stopping exactly so uh you can see a
whole question on your screen you can
just click on the answer which you feel
comfortable with which basically
explains basically what's stopping you
and uh also uh yeah you can just submit
the poll so the first option is I can
find a program uh with a fully
comprehensive curriculum uh the second
one is I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become a cloud
computer and I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos and the
last one is my work schedule won't allow
me enough time for learning so uh I can
see responses coming in already I think
um half of you have voted for the first
option uh still still people are voting
so I think I'll give like 10 seconds
more for everyone to vote and and then
share the results so I would love to
know like what exactly is stopping you
from
taking
okay uh so I'll end the poll in five
seconds uh five four three two one and
uh as you can see that half of the
folks who have joined has said that I
can't find a fully comprehensive
curriculum and one third of the folks
have said that my worst schedule won't
allow me for Learning and few of you
folks have centered I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos
I see the biggest concern in the
audience is uh I can't find a program
with the uh fully comprehensive
curriculum
as you can see in the results
Okay so shall I comment on that maybe
yeah yeah please please please yeah so
uh basically I think the first point was
uh that anyways you'll explain them in a
great detail that they don't find a
comprehensive curriculum so here we do
have a very comprehensive curriculum
then there was the other other point was
that they don't get the Practical
exposure okay so just just to tell you
guys uh the course that we are going to
offer is uh we give you a lot of
Hands-On in fact uh when I take the
trainings it is it is like uh 70
Hands-On that you get and the Hands-On
are not just the normal Labs but they
are the scenario based Labs with
end-to-end uh scenarios and a project
kind of labs in fact we have the
projects also many of the projects
running in our courses okay so that
gives you a lot of practical exposure so
there is no ways a point anyways if you
are into cloud guys if you're getting a
training into Cloud platform whether you
are getting yourself self trained or
you're getting a training from any XYZ
organization now you need to concentrate
more on the Practical business because
there is a lot of practical exposure
that you can get and you should get into
it okay so we do give a lot of practical
exposure that's without a question I I
take up 70 practicals uh in my sessions
and they are not just normal practicals
but scenario based Labs with end-to-end
um uh project kind of scenarios that we
take up and we have we do have the
projects also then
um it's difficult to learn uh from
pre-recorded videos so we have light
learning sessions so that's not a
problem wherein you can ask the
questions uh to the uh trainer as well
right and of course the comprehensive
curriculum I would uh yeah you would put
more light on to that anyways fashion
yeah so uh
for the choices you have chose so uh
will be like a comprehensive program
with the industrialized learning path
and with integrated labs and Hands-On
projects for practical experience uh
online live virtual classrooms for with
instructor and peer interaction and
flexible to fit a working professional
schedule so all the concerns are covered
in an ideal program so moving on
so sorry I got cut off like 40 minutes
so uh we have a Caltech program uh pgp
in cloud computing uh
and uh doctor what happens uh in the
live learning class do the experience
only a live lecture or does it offer
more than that Dr
of course it offers uh pretty more than
that first of all they do experience a
live learning class okay and then
um
they can ask the trainer the questions
all the queries like uh when I take the
session it's like I don't like to miss
on any query so all the queries are
resolved uh specifically uh let's say if
I am into the topic so therein there
itself either the query is resolved or
otherwise when I finish that topic
particular topic I resolve all those all
those queries so all the queries are
gets resolved uh plus you get hints off
on experience um plus it's like uh we do
give uh live examples like the um the
the examples are industry based live
examples uh that helps you in real time
operation in in in doing your uh job or
in doing your uh actual job uh the
concepts that you learn here that helps
you in your actual jobs so not just from
the certification point of view but even
from your actual uh working point of
view uh you get trained uh in my classes
here right
oh that's amazing and uh do you think
like 11 months is enough to complete uh
this pgp program like and get that
professional in cloud computing and by
only giving 10 to 15 hours per week do
you think it's possible
yes of course it's possible see because
uh the the uh the life uh classes will
happen for eight hours a week okay
Saturday Sunday four four hours and then
for uh it's 10 to 15 because you'll have
to dedicate some time on your own uh
like um practicing those labs practicing
those Concepts and uh yeah so 10 to 15
hours a week that is uh good enough a
time uh to get into the courses that we
offer and to become proficient in in in
in in the Cloud Learning paths that we
are offering here and to gain the
certifications
um The Learning platform is available 24
7. uh so basically we said that eight to
eight to ten hours usually the classes
go on and 10 to 15 hours is enough to
complete the course right if you put it
per week uh especially for working
professionals you know if or someone is
studying something else is it it will
will it be a good balance ready
yes of course it would be a great
balance because see normally on weekends
they don't have their offices and
um then during weekdays also at their
free time they can spend those one or
two hours and uh eight hours on weekends
and then uh maybe six to seven hours on
their weekdays which they have to spend
at their uh uh whatever the time they
have it available okay uh one or two
hours every day so that should be good
enough for practicing and and and
attending the live classes then 10 to 15
hours yeah wow that's amazing uh and
like how much effort do you usually need
to put like uh in order to basically
achieve this also
uh yeah I I don't feel see if you get
interested into it uh if you are when
you're joining the course and then you
feel like you are interested and then
you are able to get whatever the
um uh the the trainer is explaining you
and then you are developing your
interest into it then uh learning
becomes a fun okay and uh when it
becomes a fun so I don't uh find a
reason why you cannot do it and at the
same time you can also guys it's very
simple you can spend time with your
family also because if you are taking
four hours Saturday four hour Sunday you
have the rest of the day with your
family and um yeah and you can take out
maybe our everyday
um so to get uh the practice done on the
concepts that you have studied during
the weekdays uh sorry during the
weekends so uh that is not a big deal I
think um if you have to excel maybe if
you have to
um do something good into Cloud platform
this much you should spend and the we
people are taking good efforts here to
get the things in uh line for you yeah
wow that's interesting uh thank you so
much
thank you uh and at the end of all uh
you get a tactic ctme pgp certification
uh from caltic in cloud computing and
you get to work over 40 plus projects uh
for your portfolio including a Capstone
project uh and you can receive up to 30
CEOs from uh Caltech ctm also uh you get
a caltex ctme circle membership the the
circle membership is actually an alumni
Circle uh who actually uh you know will
be joining the batch and in this circle
you get to interact with folks from
around the world uh that basically is a
good way of networking uh and you also
get an online convocation uh where the
most interesting part is that your
family and relatives actually get to
attend your competition online together
which is pretty rare like not everyone
can make to an offline conversation
bracket so that's a really good moment
and also uh we give you a job assist uh
program uh through simply learn as well
also uh of hope everyone has heard of
caltic you can tell me on the chat here
if you have heard about caltic uh before
any attending session like if you have
heard you can say yes if not obviously
uh let me take it take you through it so
uh caltex ctme Advantage is uh Celtic
University okay I can see teacher says
Reply no okay okay this is uh lokesh
also I can see room it's okay I'll take
you through uh so Celtic uh University
uh basically the California Institute of
university is a 130 year old institution
and also uh it is a home of early matter
of many noble uh folks here uh they have
facilities like jet proportions Labs
where they can have build rockets and
space probes that will be launched into
space which is quite interesting to be a
part of an alumni like that and also the
engineers at Caltech they designed this
experience of uh you know working uh in
uh basically
and uh maybe maybe if you don't
understand this let me give an
interesting fact uh do you guys know
about Big Bang Theory if if you know
about Big Bang Theory uh the TV series
uh you can just reply yes on chat here
if you have heard about the Big Bang
Theory TV series or watched it okay I
can see the Shan moment okay a lot of
folks know about the Big Bang Theory
okay okay so the Big Bang Theory uh tv
series was actually uh you know put
around folks who are very intelligent
and uh very Noble and Noble scientist
and they had chosen the Celtic
University to Showcase in the Big Bang
TV series so yeah if you're getting into
a Celtic you are getting into Big Bang
Theory you know uh Institute as well uh
one of the top institutes and also
catechism the top five universities
Worldwide having a character ctme on
your CV is a prestigious recognizable
good to know a lot of folks actually no
talented from Big Bang Theory that's
interesting I can see Vishnu lavya and
uh
Hey folks hi
we have gotten a very interactive
audience here I must say
so uh I I want to share the eligibility
and the exercise of this program so uh
Dr purushottam wanted to ask you like uh
do uh students who come from a norm
programming background uh do they
succeed in completing this course
getting a job can you tell us more about
that
yes so I would like to tell you see
um as I uh told you before that if you
are in Cloud you don't have to be a
really good programmer okay uh you have
roles if you are a not good programmer
if you don't have good coding skills
still you can get into Cloud you can
become an administrator you can become
architect in cloud and for that you
don't need to be a programmer okay uh of
course if you want to be a developer in
Cloud then you need to have good
programming skills uh but then there are
so many letters okay so if you are from
a non-programming background there are
still a lot of avenues uh you can become
a developer sorry you can become an
administrator architect in cloud and
that's not all I mean um I have seen
people uh like joining in from different
domains uh that are non-programming
domains even non-it people also are
doing good are succeeding into Cloud
through our program and I've seen people
doing it and they are really doing good
in fact guys um if if
uh someone has told you that if you're
not a good programmer if you're not in
good in coding skills you don't have a
future in IIT forget about that let me
tell you it is not like that because in
in mnc's in it companies it's not all
about uh you be becoming a developer
only okay even if you don't have a good
programming knowledge you can still get
into ID you can still get into a lot of
roles that are there so so does in Cloud
uh like you have a lot of rows you can
be become a database guy you can become
architect you can become a administrator
you can become a security specialist and
all these things don't require good
programming skills anyways right
except for being a developer yeah that's
pretty motivating and interesting uh so
basically that means folks who actually
come from a programming background will
have an advantage right
uh no so see folks who come from a
programming background uh they can get
into the developer role okay
um so but then the folks who are not
from programming background
um
they would be equally good if they get
into other roles not the developer role
but if they want to be in the developer
role in Cloud then they have to be good
in programming but as I said that's just
one lateral okay they can get into other
rules
and yeah they can do really good into it
thank you so much I hope that makes
sense so uh let me just again
so you don't
have you can come from a non-programming
background and you will need a
bachelor's degree with at least 50 marks
and uh no work experiences required if
you don't have a work experience that's
totally okay
now moving on uh we have talked about
the skills you know uh so and uh how
does this program actually prepares you
can you tell us like uh we have talked
about the cloud computing skills you
know what's up-to-date skills you need
uh in basically to become a cloud
computing uh professional uh but can you
tell take us like step by step through
the cloud computing program uh which
actually builds your skill you know uh
so can you take us to that
yeah sure
so see basically
um this is the um step-by-step procedure
of uh what the different courses that we
offer in the
um postgraduate program in cloud
computing at simply learn okay along
with Caltech University so um basically
it starts with your orientation session
for cloud computing program okay so
there is one orientation session from
the uh from The Faculty of Caltech USA
that could take this session then once
you complete this session uh then you
start with AWS course that is AWS
Solutions architect associate okay and
uh this would this would run for 40
hours or so and then uh you get trained
into different AWS Services uh in this
course like the core services are
related to compute virtual machines uh
networks databases storage and plus
application Level Services a few of them
like SNS sqs and so on okay so that few
study in AWS Solutions architect course
and of course a lot of Hands-On would be
there and once you complete that then we
do give one week of Gap there and so
that you can recharge yourself and then
get into another course uh that is
Microsoft certified Azure administrator
so when you get into Azure uh there are
two compulsory courses that you will
have to opt for uh that is Microsoft
Azure administrator is at 104 that is on
the admin and when you get a good
knowledge on different admin Services uh
like the core Services compute storage
networks databases plus uh users IEM uh
like Azure ID and stuff okay so you
study all of them in this and there are
a lot of Hands-On again in this and once
you do this course then you get into
Azure infrastructure solutions that is
designing a Microsoft Azure
infrastructure Solutions is that 305
that is nothing but Azure architect
course okay
and guys after you finish this uh so so
here you you will be able to make design
decisions let's say if uh two services
are there to accomplish your task or
there are more than one services so uh
which one uh suits you or which one
would be better for you to opt for okay
uh okay so
um uh as per your company's requirement
companies budgets and so on so once you
do this course uh then the final thing
comes into picture and see after every
course you will have a course and
project okay and once you do this
architect course then you have the
um mega project you can say that is the
Capstone project which will have uh the
uh I mean which will test you on the
knowledge of the services from Azure and
AWS both okay so uh there will be
problem statements which will which will
use the services of azure AWS both and
you will be able to
um accomplish that if you have knowledge
of both the services then you'll be able
to then succeed in Capstone project
which again would be man entered by by
your Mentor one of the trainer he or she
will help you out in that and then once
you complete this uh then you get the
coveted uh certification from Caltech
University
um that is the postgraduate program in
cloud computing from Caltech USA which
is ranked as second topmost I think in
the world and apart from that after you
complete every course you get a course
and project uh I mean you get a course
in project of course and once you do
that then you get a certificate for
every course from Simply learn as well
and apart from this guys there are
electives as you can see here so now
these electives as the name says these
are not compulsory things to get that
Caltech certification okay but then if
you are interested and if you want to
opt for any of these electives or all of
these electives you can go for it and of
course there will be live classes in
them also almost in all of them and live
classes for compulsory courses would be
there so if you go with one or all of
the electives you can go with it and of
course there will be a certificate at
the end of every course for this as well
and these electives comes to you for no
extra cost uh like whatever you pay for
your certification in cloud computing
form uh Caltech uh like for these
compulsory courses in that only uh you
can opt for one or all of these
electives with no extra cost okay and
here you can get into uh devops on cloud
um Google Cloud platform architect
training as well AWS database migration
systems associate AWS developer
associate Azure uh developer associate
and uh of course the culture cloud
computing master classes will be taken
by Caltech professors okay so uh that
also you can have uh
um you can you can just attend that as
well right okay yeah uh talking about
the electives uh so electors as you can
see on the screen uh which drum has so
very very nicely explained about that so
uh these adjectives are actually a part
of the program you don't you there's
these are optionals it is up to you if
you want to take it but there are there
is no extra charge for this this comes
with a part of the program uh the amount
which we charge for the program is
included in the program so that is up to
you if you want to take up the electives
uh it is up to you what you choose uh so
yeah moving on to the next one
so uh so there are a lot of tools and uh
platforms you will be learning about in
this program you're seeing very few
tools and platforms right now on the
screen uh so uh but but Dr like how do
you go on to uh learn all these tools
and platforms within just 11 months
uh so see these are the services in in
Azure and AWS and uh
uh when you when you go through those
courses of course you'll run all of them
I mean and these are just few of them
mentioned here there'll be a lot more
services that you'll be learning in the
program like just to give you an example
that mentioned uh here are so ec2 is a
service in AWS that is elastic compute
Cloud that helps you to create your
virtual server service in Amazon AWS
Cloud okay then dynamodb as I told you
before uh it is for nosql data you can
manage or you can create your nosql
databases in AWS Lambda is serverless
compute service in AWS then
um you can accomplish your task by
creating functions so you don't have to
create servers here these servers would
be uh created in the back end by Amazon
and you don't know whether what servers
they are creating and how they are doing
it so you you just write your code in
the form of functions and then
um let the infrastructure let the
servers if at all required be created by
Amazon at the back end you don't have to
worry about that then of course S3 is
simple storage service it is used for
storing your object based data in cloud
in AWS there are many more and in Azure
of course you can have a sure container
service that can be used for Loosely
coupled applications also for for for
for uh having your micro Services based
application running in containers which
are nothing but lightweight virtual
machines anyways I'll not go get into
the details of that otherwise it would
mean a lot of things that I'll have to
say here okay
um then of course uh whatever you create
and assure it is in the form of resource
manager models okay so Azure resource
manager model you'll get into that also
in detail when you join this course yeah
uh so um just curious you know like you
talked about the Capstone visits uh so
maybe uh assuming that folks actually
might not know the importance of a
Capstone project to have in your resume
in portfolio and uh also uh what exactly
is a captioning project for someone who
has no idea about it can you tell us
more about that
yeah so see Capstone projects uh
uh you can like they are like end-to-end
projects okay uh so basically they are
like end-to-end projects means what uh
when you learn Azure when you learn AWS
both of the things okay so
um now you have done a project on AWS
you have done a project on Azure also so
now you can mix the services of so in
Capstone project it would be a
combination of both AWS and Azure and
the services from AWS as well as as
Azure would be used uh for doing this
project okay so you would be using the
services from AWS from Azure to do this
project so the point is that it would it
would have a mix of both these services
and it would be a real true experience
it will give you like a real uh use case
real experience in your industries
um that you get the industry like
projects so that kind of projects you
will get it into the Capstone projects
okay
that's really amazing yeah so see it's
written they uh they will mimic the real
life scenarios for you okay
wow that's pretty interesting uh also
the industry-based handling projects uh
they will be adding to your portfolio
how does this help in different
different categories of you know a
person a cloud company person will be
going to
yeah so of course uh it would add to
your portfolio so so these are the
examples of some Capstone projects that
you can see it out there like deploying
an online Video subscription application
on the cloud or online Healthcare
application on cloud restaurant
application in Cloud deploying card
management applications to Cloud so
these are like end-to-end projects when
you develop them when you do these
Capstone projects and you put it in your
profiles you put it in your resume so
they are going to of course uh impress
the employers okay when they would test
you or they would like to have you on uh
in their organization of course that's
really
also uh we actually have a simple plan
community that actually supports you if
you become a part of this program uh
where you can interact with your
instructors there is a learning platform
which is available 24 7. uh the caltex
also assigns a program manager which
actually uh you know uh keeps checking
with simply one is you know having the
same standards of quality for the
program uh and also you will also be
interacting with your peers uh and
learning teams uh you will have a great
access to curriculum resources as well
and you will also have a product manager
in this community
now moving on to the learning
environment uh the learning environment
will be uh basically including managing
your curriculum the live virtual
classroom it will be having test demos
caption project which we talked about uh
an overview of that and also our
progress tracking uh which will actually
help in unlocking your certificates and
also support tools which we talked about
uh can you take us to the learning
environment Dr purushottam for maybe to
get give them an idea basically what
this program has
yes sure so maybe I'll just share my
screen for that
please correct yeah meanwhile folks
while you're sharing your screen uh I
can see a lot of you folks have actually
asked questions on the Q a so we'll be
taking them one by one in some time uh
once Dr brushes takes us through uh the
learning environment which will actually
give you a better idea uh what actually
happens inside the program so yeah
please go ahead yeah sure I hope my
screen is visible
yeah so as you can see here uh we have a
post we have this postgraduate program
in cloud computing and if you get into
this course as already stated in the
courses you can find this orientation
session for Trail Tech pgb cloud and if
you get into this course uh you will
have a self learning section uh now this
self learning section will have a
pre-recorded session of some uh good
trainer already there okay and then so
this is orientation session so you will
have the pre-recorded session of
orientation session already here Plus in
the live class you'll get access to
um
the recording of the live session that
you have attended on orientation okay so
the recording of that you will find it
in in the live tab in the live classes
here okay
um so in live classes you have two tabs
my classes and past classes so in past
classes you will see the lecture
recordings of your sessions and in the
my classes you can see uh the upcoming
sessions uh that you will have to attend
the upcoming live sessions okay so that
are there
okay then in the certificate section uh
like uh uh so so see even for this
orientation session that you'll attend
you once you complete this you can
unlock your certificate so you have to
complete this class uh one live class
and uh once you do that you can unlock
your certificate for this okay so this
is the first orientation session then
once you complete this then you get into
the AWS Solutions architect course that
was already discussed from that slide so
once you get into this course okay
um so again in this course you will have
the same thing the self learning section
which which will cover the uh recordings
of some good trainer already available
here okay and then in the live classes
you will see the lecture recordings of
your live classes that you would attend
maybe on Saturday Sundays so those
lecture recordings of those classes you
will see here so that if you miss on
some class or miss on some part or you
want to revisit some part so you can
always go through through these
recordings okay so they will be handily
available to you okay and apart from
that
um apart from that uh in the in the in
the past classes I mean that that would
be visible the recordings will be in the
past classes apart from that uh the the
upcoming classes that you will have you
will see it in this my classes section
okay uh then
um this is important then in assessment
fee you get access to projects and the
test okay so you have three projects
here sorry three tests here plus one two
three four five projects so guys uh the
point is that uh one project would be
mentored or all of them in one of the
mentoring class uh by the trainer at the
end of the course okay uh so they will
Mentor you they'll help you to do one of
the project at least out of these five
and
um
apart from that these assessments also
would be uh like mentored uh or or you
will have to do it as well and then
um so so so there is something called a
certificate so to to unlock this
certificate what is the requirement is
you will have to complete uh either
eighty percent of the uh or more of the
live learning classes and 85 percent of
the self learning videos okay to um
so this is this is One requirement and
then you will also have to do one
project out of these projects or add one
simulation test with a sixty percent of
the marks uh once you do that then
you'll be able to unlock this
certificate right guys and then there is
reference material section which
contains the ebooks data fries plus
apart from that if the trainer wants to
share you some extra material he or she
can do so that as well okay so that all
is here
and then apart from that uh uh there is
this practice lab session so this is
very interesting this practice Labs guys
so in practice Labs uh basically see uh
when I say you have a lot of Hands-On in
AWS assure so how would you be doing
those Hands-On so you do you need to
create your account into AWS or assure
so the answer is no guys maybe with many
other people you would like to they
would they would let you create your
accounts but with us with simply learn
uh we don't ask you to create your
personal accounts with your credit cards
and your debit cards okay you we provide
you that lab environment we provide you
the sandbox environment so you can go to
this AWS or AWS Labs here and you can
just launch the lab and um uh you can
start using the lab from here and so you
don't need to create your personal
accounts to to to access the lab
environment so this is very interesting
and this is very uh advantageous for you
when you join our program here okay so
this is for AWS Labs likewise you have
for a sure like see uh the lab has
started so there is a sign in link uh
you can get into that sign in link and
uh of course uh you can uh just to give
you a small demo here so you can get
into the sign in link and then uh you
can you can put this username and then
the password and uh you can you can get
started with the lab okay
uh so you can just put up this username
and then uh you can just put up this
password as well okay
and you can get started with let's say
AWS environment and you can start doing
the lab see here it is how simple it is
okay and yeah you can start doing your
Labs here okay see you are into AWS
environment similarly for Azure you get
the same so this is about one course
okay guys that is architect so once you
complete this uh then you get the access
to uh I mean you can then do the az104
certification that is on Azure associate
and then
um
in in that also you will have similar
kinds of tabs so I'll quickly go through
it so in the self learning section and
you will see the uh uh pre-recorded uh
sessions awesome good trainer okay and
then in the in the in the in the live
classes you will see the lecture
recordings uh again of uh the live
classes that you will have in the past
classes and in my classes you will see
the recordings of the new classes okay
and
um I mean uh not the recordings the new
classes that would be scheduled then
assessments of course you have the
projects and the uh what
um
the assignments and similar kind of uh
requirement you have to unlock the
certificate like you'll have to complete
one um live class or sorry 80 of live
class or 80 or self 85 percent of self
learning videos plus uh project you will
have to complete to unlock the
certificate one project out of these
many projects okay and yes you get this
uh lab environment here also like AWS
you can launch the Azure Labs also so
you didn't you you don't need to have
the uh what your personal account
created in Azure to do the labs there
okay uh so that's there and of course
after this uh you have 305
certifications so similar kind of
requirements there also guys uh you get
in um okay uh and similar type of
environment there also you have self
learning then
um the of course the live classes
section and uh
apart from that uh there is like the
assessment uh I mean uh life classes is
there and then uh there is like
assessment and then the material section
and of course the practice labs are
there also and uh to unlock the
certificate you have the similar uh kind
of requirements that is uh uh you have
to attend the eighty percent of Life
classes or 85 percent of self-learning
videos and plus you'll have to complete
a project to unlock the uh certificate
okay so that's it and so this is what
are the compulsory events and then
lastly you will have uh the cloud
computing Capstone project okay so in
the cloud computing Capstone project uh
uh
what you will have access to uh so in
cloud computing Capstone project
um again you have self learning videos
see live classes uh and uh apart from
that the assessment uh wherein you have
so many uh these captured projects and
in in self learning videos there'll be a
mentoring session from pre-recorded from
some trainer and in live classes you
will go through a live uh session that
uh would uh be uh for that the recording
would be available here which you can
um attend I mean which you can listen to
later on as well and plus in this
practice Labs out here in the Capstone
project you will find there are labs for
Azure also and for AWS as well so
um there are labs for Azure and ews both
because the Capstone project will will
test you on the knowledge of both okay
so you can use the labs of both okay and
yes so that's there and guys so once you
complete this Capstone project then
you'll be able to unlock your PG program
certificate from caltex University
correct so that is there and apart from
that there are electives also as I told
you so you have electives for master
class uh which you can attend Plus for
204 similar kind of things you'll have
live classes the self recorded sessions
uh uh uh right so here also in these
courses in almost all of these courses
so AWS developer Associates associate
database migration Google Cloud
professional architect devops on AWS
okay so all of these few can attend as
well okay so that's there and of course
uh you can unlock your certificate after
you at least complete the uh compulsory
courses if not the electives okay so
that is there
and apart from that if you would see
here there's an important thing called
as Community Forum so in this community
guys uh basically you plus your trainers
plus your other peers your other peer
Learners all of you plus the support
team from uh simply learn all of you can
interact here plus if the trainer wants
to share some uh
um some extra material to you he or she
can share it in this community Forum
okay and yeah so this is a good place to
interact with your trainer with your uh
after the class maybe as well with the
support team and simply learn with the
um with the other peers uh of your batch
uh okay so uh here you can interact in
this community Forum okay so that is
there and yeah and then there is you see
this help support so I think there is
24x7 support uh for uh queries uh that
you have so you can chat with us uh and
you can get it solved here here okay so
that is there okay I've gone through my
courses uh and then in my resources you
can see uh we have the YouTube recording
for uh multiple webinars going on okay
so you can actually access to those
resources also from uh this section here
from my resources okay and my courses
already I've told you yeah so this is I
think uh uh the explanation on uh the uh
LMS learning management system that you
will have access to once you join our
course right okay
right then Russia I hope this is good
thank you so much for teaching us
through the learning environment thank
you
I'll I'll just stop sharing then yeah
thank you sure sure
yeah thank you
let me just uh
uh so before we go and talk about the
learner outcomes uh and share you more
about the course so we have uh the
Celtic has global leaders as program
advisors uh like Rick Hefner and John
Wentz uh so they basically make sure
that uh simply learn is uh you know
leading up to the standards when
actually providing that uh you know
value in terms of uh this program uh by
Cal date
and we'll be talking about the learner
outcomes uh so uh the interesting part
is we have Learners from world-class
organizations and they come from diverse
Industries like IBM Deloitte Amazon
Microsoft Aurora kill Barclays and they
also come from different Industries
which we have already talked about like
from I.T software product e-commerce
and a few of the success stories which
you can see on your screen right now uh
you can see Jonah uh who actually took a
career break and uh when she actually
took up this course and she uh got a
decent job over with a 50 salary hike
even after a career break which is quite
hard actually when you are in a career
break you have all these fears you know
will I even get a salary which I was
getting in my previous job uh do I have
to start over again uh so getting a 50
salary hike is a really good uh you know
motivation to have in order to take up
this program and we can also look at
Rajiv Rajiv actually transitioned his
career and uh got a really good salary
hi kitchen
yeah in fact that is a great fear in
people's mind like when uh when they are
like um uh they are not good uh doing
the job or when they when they when they
want to have a break uh in their careers
but then they are really the fear of
getting a I mean losing their job if
they would uh get into a break and stuff
like that so uh even if they are not
interested at one particular point in
their lives in their careers they still
have to continue uh so this is a great
example that even after after a career
week she could achieve this this thing
yeah
yeah I I agree I agree uh also uh we
also have a job assist program uh by IM
jobs we have partnered with uh where we
actually give you an access to premium I
am jobs coded and also a resume review
and create Services as you can see
within five to seven days you will get
your first Contact and also one-on-one
interview sessions because obviously uh
prepping for an interview after getting
the certification is the most important
uh thing you need to do uh so uh I can
see uh a lot of you folks have already
put a lot of questions in the Q and if
you have taken a few questions and
obviously you'll be taking uh you know
other questions in just few minutes
before that I would love to know that uh
if you would like to enroll in this
program
since somebody
okay let me relaunch the board so I want
to know like would you like to enroll in
this program are you interested yes or
no would you like to get a call after
I'm a learning consultant and get to
explore more about the course the
questions you have the queries you have
will get answered
I can see a lot of you folks have
already started voting in uh so you can
see a pop-up on your screen uh like
would you like to enroll in this program
uh are you curious about this program
you can either select yes or no uh as an
option and if you select yes you'll be
getting uh a call from a learning
consultant from Simply learn and also uh
uh like okay and whatever questions you
have about the program obviously we'll
try to answer as many questions as
possible here as well uh I can see uh a
lot of you folks have already answered
and uh I think I can see the 70 of the
folks have answered yes uh folks uh who
actually have not answered until now uh
I'll be closing the poll in 10 seconds
so you have 10 seconds more to answer
the poll like uh would you like to
enroll in this program would you like to
explore about more about the program uh
yeah I can see
most of the folks have actually voted
and submitted so you can see a polarity
scheme for the infinity laptop or mobile
would you like to enroll in the program
you can choose the option yes or no
okay I'll end the poll and I'll just
share the results immediately so I we
can see 70 31 of the folks actually are
interested in learning the program
so uh folks who are interested I'll just
let you know the enrolling steps uh so
it's very easy uh users need to submit
an application uh you can apply at uh
ask us at uh simplylearn.ed you can
share uh you want to submit an
application uh based on that if your
application will go into review by
Caltech ctme reviews uh ask based on
your qualifications which are required
as per the eligibility which we have
already discussed and also the step
three uh once you have basically gone
through these steps a learning person
can be contact you with an admission
offer yes we do have a bonus offer as
well for folks who are attending this
program
and we have a orientation of current
audition starting at 30th of orders and
the classes will be starting for this
particular cohort on 2nd of September uh
so uh yeah and the price for this cloud
computing uh pgp program by caltic is of
only 1 lakh fifty nine thousand uh
and uh if you are looking for a
financing option as well it is available
for as low as uh five La 5411
and uh if you want to get started you
can actually mail us at uh ask us at
simplywin.net
and also uh just to let you know we have
a very limited set of cohort uh why do
we do that is because we actually limit
it only to 25 to 30 folks in one
particular batch uh because we want you
to have full attention from our
instructors uh NPS like uh and while
interacting as well uh while putting
going through the program so to have a
quality experience while you're studying
uh understanding that you actually might
be working somewhere as well I can see
those questions you know coming on the Q
a section as well
and uh good afternoon
how soon do you plan to enroll
so you can see
hi uh so sorry folks uh I got a cut off
in between so yeah I was asking to call
soon do you plan to enroll uh do you
plan to enroll immediately uh do you
plan to enroll within three months do
you plan to enroll within six months uh
if you plan to enroll from more than six
months from now on you can choose all
these options on your screenwriter and
just submit it so we can get to know
where exactly do you plan to enroll for
folks who have selected you know they
want to enroll in this program
okay I can see a responses coming in uh
already and I can see few of your folks
have already voted uh for folks who have
not voted I would suggest like just see
a photo on your screen and you just need
to just select how soon do you plan to
enroll do you plan to enroll immediately
for folks who are selected they want to
enroll in this program do you want to
enroll within three months that is the
second option the third one is like
within six months and the fourth one is
more than six months from now
okay I can see a lot of uh folks have
already voted
okay uh I'll be sharing the result in
five four three two one
you will be able to see the whole
results in your screen
yeah the result by the way Russia is
60 of the folks would like to get
started within three months yeah so 40
are looking a little farther up
you know so uh I think let's go to the Q
a section folks have been waiting with
their questions uh in the Q a section so
Dr parishion let's take us uh take a few
questions from the Q a section which
have not been answered so uh let us
start with uh uh he has asked that what
are the requirements of AWS cloud
computing so I think we have answered
this one already yeah
okay let me take one from uh himanshu so
hello my name is himanshu and I
currently work as technical technical
chat support for a cellular service
provider ex-infinity and I am planning
to learn web development and got this
email for cloud computing so will it be
easier to learn cloud computing after
learning web development
see uh it would be good because uh I
wouldn't say it would be easier but then
it would be good if you're a web
developer uh because
um uh when you when you create your
websites how you can host it in Cloud
how you can deploy it on the servers in
the cloud is something
um that you will be able to study here
and then you will be able to do it here
so um it would be very nice uh to study
and to get into this role
um and you can actually deploy your
websites in cloud and you can
um
like you can host your websites in Cloud
that way yeah so you can really do that
um interesting I hope that answers your
question
uh so somewhere else like is it possible
to learn devops before learning cloud
computing
yeah it is uh possible to learn devops
uh sorry can you come again Russia uh is
it possible to learn devops
developers
before learning okay see you can always
learn uh devops before Cloud also
uh that is not a problem uh but then if
you want to learn devops in Cloud uh
then that goes hand in hand like you
learn cloud and then you learn devops
into it so if you want to learn devops
in Cloud so I would suggest you to go
with practitioner certification in cloud
and then go with devops in Cloud okay uh
but then if you want to learn devops uh
any on-premises environment maybe with
the free tier tools like Jenkins
terraform uh so of course you can do
that without or before learning cloud as
well
I hope that answers your question
but it would always help you uh in Cloud
uh that if you first learn cloud and
then you if you learn devops so you can
learn devops with the freeway Tools in
on-premises Plus in Cloud uh you have
good devops tools uh that can help you
to learn the devops in Cloud right
okay I hope that answers your question
okay I can see Praveen has asked like
having a knowledge in cloud is okay or
certification is married I think we have
already answered this one
next one is how is adoption of cloud in
Middle East Africa region or is it at
early stage as of now
see I would suggest strongly suggest you
don't go by the regions because uh uh it
is a global thing now okay so don't get
get yourself uh just uh stuck up with
your regions like Middle East or uh
Africa of course
um uh maybe it it may not be uh too much
uh out there I I personally don't have
much much knowledge into that but then I
would say uh that uh these public Cloud
platforms may not have their uh good
regions in those uh regions okay that
you stated uh but of course when I talk
about cloud or otherwise also guys the
um
the the people are like connected with
each other across the globe so you don't
have to really stuck up to your region
and uh because uh sooner or later it is
going to flourish in your region also
and even if it is not uh today uh then
you're not just going to work in your
region uh uh like world has become a
small village isn't it so we all are
connected so
I hope that answers your question uh
thank you so much uh okay steps to
become architects
steps to become architect so of course
you can start with practitioner and then
you can get into the admin role and then
you become an architect so have a have a
certificate have have knowledge on
practitioner skills then the admin
skills and then the architect skills
then when you do have that uh and when
you then have some experience in your
organization uh in the uh in in in some
architect roles then then you become a
uh or uh some experience otherwise also
then you then you can become a good
architect right so when you will be
solving some use cases you'll be making
the design decisions of course if you
learn these courses you'll be able to do
so and you can become a successful
architect then
initially I have worked on firewall
devices and then for a few months back
started on Azure security so for that I
have to do Cloud practitioners and
security and what are the skills are
needed sideways
see if you want to be on the security
side then of course practitioner and
security certifications are the good Pro
those itself would be enough if you want
to be on the security side right but
then of course if you want to be in on
architect site then you'll have to go
with architect certification but from
security point of view
um get into the details of the security
services in cloud and have good
knowledge of them and that can help you
okay uh Praveen has asked like uh which
one is better offering course or online
course ah okay so see uh now
um I would say online course now you
will say because uh I am promoting PG
program in cloud computing and that's
why I'll say online course
um but but let me tell you that is not
the uh actual reason uh the actual
reason is Guy c
um I'll tell you if you are in let's say
one region if let's say I'm from nagpur
India
um I may not have expertise of a
particular area
I may not have a good persons that have
the expertise in one particular area in
nagpur region but then I may have it in
Bangalore okay I may have it in outside
India as well correct so then the point
becomes is if I go and opt for offline
courses I may get people around here who
are into that particular uh training
business but they are not the excellent
ones they are not the best ones in that
business but then probably the best
person is in Bangalore sitting in
Bangalore so how I can have access to
him so either I'll have to travel there
and get the excess or otherwise I can
get into so it's not always possible to
travel everywhere and get the excess of
that those resource persons so uh with
the online thing in picture sitting in
my city here I can get myself trained uh
with the expert uh person uh the expert
resource person
um at the convenience of sitting in my
home correct so
um that is there and of course uh even
the gobit times have taught us uh that
we can effectively learn in online mode
as we can do it in offline mode as well
definitely uh I can see one interesting
question uh iron Microsoft certified uh
devops Engineer Expert and Microsoft
certified Azure solution architect
exponent but I don't feel qualified to
work in real life what would be your
advice for me to get more experience uh
so see as I said I I think you must have
uh list uh listen to my one statement
that here we don't just prepare for
certifications we prepare you with real
time uh like at least I prepare you with
real-time use cases and then uh
real-time Hands-On environment
end-to-end lab-based activities that can
help you to do work in your real
environment so see uh there are two
aspects uh or two sides of a coin
getting yourself prepared for the
certification and then getting yourself
prepared to work in the Real Environment
so we concentrate on both the things
here correct so we concentrate on making
you uh prepare for your
um uh What uh for doing the jobs in your
real-time environment and for getting
them done
um in an effective manner right
so yeah that way you can go yeah I hope
that answers your question uh I couldn't
see a name there uh I think well they
will be taking the last question so I
already took the Azure certificates I
only read the AWS and Google Cloud
courses will I need to attend the Azure
courses as well
uh see if you are going with
postgraduate program in cloud computing
with simply learned then yes uh that is
a requirement okay uh but then don't
worry even if you have taken that
courses you will get something new or
something interesting as I said Hands-On
activities and then uh the project uh
stuff end-to-end labs and real examples
so that would help you okay uh so uh
yeah I would say if you are going with
postgraduate program with simply learn
then you will have to go with those
courses but those will only add to your
knowledge uh I would suggest
um yeah that's what Russia I can say uh
otherwise uh maybe with other courses in
Cleveland I am not aware of that you can
be a better person to answer them yeah
okay uh I think I think that is a really
good answer
session
yeah so I would love to know uh like for
folks who have chosen like they would
like to enroll in this course uh how
would you uh you need our assistance to
enroll so do you need a resisting to
enroll yes or no uh you can see your
poll on your screen you can either click
yes and no like if you need assistance
to enroll so we'll be helping you with
that so I can see folks I've already
started voting so that's great but I
would want all all the folks who have
not voted to vote as well so you'll get
to know if you need an assistant to
enroll uh you can select yes if you
don't need it you can select no I can
see uh you know um there's a lot of up
and on going on between yes or no and
yes a lot of people are actually
answering yes okay uh so I'll be giving
10 more seconds for this whole uh for a
few books who have not uh voted uh so do
you need assistance to enroll uh you can
select the option yes if you would want
an assistant you can select an option no
if you don't want the assistance I would
recommend like take this so uh so yeah
five more seconds five four three two
one so let me just end up uh
I can see that 40 of the folks have said
yes they want an assistant and 60 books
of sometimes so yeah moving on uh we
actually are towards the end of the
session thank you so much for joining us
thank you for every everyone being
patient thank you Dr purushottam for
taking your time out and you're taking
us through the program view for
character Computing bgp program uh your
insights and the learning environment
which your take us to works very
valuable and uh thank you so much drum
for taking uh your time out for this
webinar
thank you thank you Russia thank you
everyone and thank you Russia and simply
learn for inviting me here and uh yeah
thank you guys for listening to us
thank you thank you so much folks for
joining one last thing uh in case you
want you won't have uh want to ask more
questions if you have
to says ask us at civilian.net also if
you want to know more about the program
you can just canvas code it will take
you to the program cloud computing uh
broadcast bgp uh by Calvin so thank you
so much we'll be ending the session now
thank you so much folks for joining what
an interactive uh audience and so many
questions you know we have answered so
thank you so much thank you for being a
really good
yeah uh Russia there is one question I
would like to answer
um which which one would be more uh I
mean when when learner is asking there
is more of AWS in this course which one
beers more uh it looks like he says no
so I would like to say it is it is both
like uh you have like in fact you'll see
uh two Azure courses one zero four and
three zero five in one AWS so both are
um and like equally marked the AWS and
Aishwarya uh so both will learn here
plus uh in electives you can even learn
Google architect codes as well
I think this is asked by Chris uh if I
can see yeah
I guess I hope uh you know it answers
your question thank you so much Dr
purushottam for taking uh one last
question as well thank you so much we'll
be ending the session now uh all of you
who have joined uh from India so have a
good night and other folks have a good
morning uh good evening good afternoon
and a good day uh good night to all
thank you so much
thank you